okay let's talk about one of the most
challenging things
one of the things i unfortunately am
very afraid of
being human
allegedly
you wrote an essay on death and
consciousness in which you write a note
certainly the fear of death has been one
of the greatest driving forces in the
history of thought and in the formation
of the character of civilization and yet
it is under acknowledged the great book
on the subject the denial of death by
ernest becker deserves a reconsideration
i'm russian so i have to ask you about
this what's the role of death and life
see
you would have enjoyed coming to our
house because uh
my wife is russian and we also have we
have a piano of such spectacular
qualities you wouldn't
you would have freaked out
but anyway we'll let all that go
so um the context in which i i remember
that essay uh sort of this was from
maybe the 90s or something
and um
i used to publish in a journal called
the journal of consciousness studies
because i was i was interested in these
endless debates about consciousness and
science
which
certainly continued today
and
i was
interested in how the fear of death
and the denial of death played into
different philosophical approaches to
consciousness
because
i uh i think on the one hand
uh
this sort of
sentimental
school of dualism meaning the feeling
that there's something apart from the
physical brain some kind of soul or
something else
is obviously motivated in a sense by a
hope that that whatever whatever that is
will survive death and continue and
that's a
very core aspect of a lot of the world
religions not all of them not not really
but you know
most of them
um
the
thing i noticed is that the the opposite
of those which might be the sort of
hardcore no the brain's a computer and
that's it
in a sense
we're
motivated in the same way with a
remarkably similar chain of of uh of
arguments which is
no i the brain's a computer and i'm
going to figure it out in my lifetime
and upload it upload myself and i'll
live forever
that's interesting yeah that's that's
like the implied thought right yeah and
so it's kind of this in a funny way it's
it's the same thing
it's uh
um
it's peculiar
that you to notice that these people who
would appear to be opposites in
character and cultural references and uh
and in their ideas actually are
remarkably similar
and and to to to an incredible degree
this sort of hardcore uh
computationalist idea about uh the brain
has turned into medieval christianity
with together like there's the they're
the people who are afraid that if you
have the wrong thought you'll piss off
the super ais of the future who will
come back and zap you
and and all that stuff yeah it's like
it's really it's really turned into
medieval christianity all over again uh
this is the ernest becker's idea that
death
the fear of death is the warm at the
core
which is like
that's the that's the core motivator of
everything we see humans have created
the question is if that fear of
mortality is somehow core it's like a
prerequisite
so
what you just you just moved across this
vast cultural chasm
uh that separates me from most of my
colleagues in a way and i can't answer
what you just said on the level without
this huge deconstruction yes should i do
it yes what's the chasm okay
let us travel across this vastness okay
i don't believe in ai i don't think
there's any ai there's just algorithms
we make them we control them now
they're tools they're not creatures now
this is something that rubs a lot of
people the wrong way
and don't i know it when i was young my
main mentor was marvin minsky who's the
principal author of
the computer as creature
rhetoric that we still use
he was the first person to have the idea
at all but he certainly
populated
the ai culture with most of its tropes i
would say uh because a lot of so people
will say oh did you hear this new idea
about ai and i'm like yeah i heard it in
1978 sure yeah i remember that
so marvin was really the person and uh
marvin and i used to argue
all the time about the stuff because i
always rejected it and of all of his
um
of all of his uh i wasn't formally his
student but i worked for him as a
researcher but of all of his students
and student-like people
of his young adoptees
um
i think i was the one who argued with
him about this stuff in particular and
he loved it yeah i would have loved to
hear that conversation it was fun did
you ever converse to a place
oh no no so the very last time i saw him
he was quite frail and and uh
i was in uh in boston and i was going to
the old house in brookline his amazing
house
and one of our mutual friends said hey
listen marvin's so frail
don't do the argument with him
don't argue about ai
you know and so i said but marvin loves
that and so i showed up and he's like he
was frail he looked up and he said
are you ready to argue
[Laughter]
he's such an amazing person
so um
it's hard to summarize this because it's
decades of stuff
the first thing to say
is that nobody can claim absolute
knowledge about whether somebody or
something else is conscious or not
this is all a matter of faith and in
fact
i think the whole idea of faith needs to
be updated so it's not about god but
it's just about stuff in the universe we
we have faith in each other being
conscious and then um
i used to frame this as a thing called
the circle of empathy
in my old papers and then
um
it turned into a thing for the animal
rights movement so i noticed peter
singer using it i don't know if it was
coincident or
but anyway we there's this idea that you
draw a circle around yourself and the
stuff inside is more like you might be
conscious might be deserving of your
empathy of your consideration and the
stuff outside the circle isn't
and
um outside the circle might be a rock
or
i don't know
uh and that circle is fundamentally
based on faith
well your faith and what is and what
isn't it the thing about this circle
is it can't be pure faith it also has
it's also a pragmatic decision and this
is where things get complicated
if you try to make it too big
you suffer from incompetence
if you say
i don't want to kill a bacteria i will
not brush my teeth i don't know like
what do you do like you know like
there's a there's a competence question
where you do have to draw the line
people who make it too small become
cruel
people are so clanished and political
and so worried about themselves ending
up on the bottom
of society that they are always ready to
gang up on some designated group and so
there's always these people who are
being tried we're always trying to shove
somebody out of the circle
and so aren't you shoving ai outside the
circle well give me a second all right
so so there's a pragmatic consideration
here yeah and so uh and and uh the the
biggest questions are probably fetuses
and animals lately but ai is getting
there
now with ai
i think
uh
and i've had this discussion so many
times people say but aren't you afraid
if you exclude ai you'd be cruel to some
consciousness
and then i would say well if you include
ai
you make yourself
you you exclude yourself from being able
to be a good engineer or designer and so
you're facing incompetence immediately
so like i really think we need to
subordinate algorithms and be much more
skeptical of them
you